il ya un seul appareil qu'il faut aller
voir sur le salon fait le
[Musique]
faut il s'en faut
à qui on est au mwc à barcelone 2e jour
du mwc
j'arrivais ya quelques temps quelques
jours des conférences voilà donc ça
continue aujourd'hui on va les voir
sonic a présenté un smartphone avec un
écran format 21/9 format qui est assez
cool au final très intéressant vous
allez voir il ya plein d'avantagés
la question maintenant c'est est ce
qu'il va réussir à séduire est ce que
sony va réussir son pari là dessus mais
avant toute chose souffert faire un
petit tour ne la chante j'aime bien le
petit rituel de la tour du tour de la
chambre d'hôtel je sais pas si vous le
savez mais l'année dernière lorsque je
suis partie au mwc
c'est vous ça c'était un peu la galère
airbnb qui me plante la veille à 21h
puis me retrouvais loger après dans un
cagibi sans fenêtre c'est un peu moyen
cette année c'est pas du tout ça
explosion
regardez-moi ça 180 c'est magnifique
il ya de quoi bosser il y a de quoi lire
il ya de quoi à part une petite vue et
salle de bain je crois que il
franchement j'ai jamais vu ça dans le
jeu très content c'est plutôt cool vous
pouvez vous l'avez l2 jusque là vous
gérer cette forme d'art vous pouvez
prendre votre bas et il ya le membre
dusan comme ça si vous voulez éviter des
potes qu'est ce que vous voulez après
tout vous pouvez le faire et après tout
le monde cela c'est formidable bon bref
sur ces belles paroles on file
directement roi ewc il va y avoir plein
de petites tailles mourir aussi
[Musique]
solucom et voit l'arrivée sur le stand
de sony alors sony alors ces différents
smartphones xperia one qu'un grand
smartphone format 21/9 hyper cool xperia
10 xperia 10 plus il ya plein de
nouveautés c'est très intéressant
on va en parler ce que je vous propose
c'est qu'on aille voir ça me va le
regard plus sur ses smartphones
mais aujourd'hui avec famille de sony
avec des nouveaux smartphones qui ont
été lancés grosse actu côté de chez sony
et surtout le 21 2e chez sony c'est quoi
l'idée pourquoi du 21e aujourd'hui alors
on lance pour la première fois sur un
smartphone
un format donc cinéma le 21
format cinémascope directement sur sur
les mobiles pour justement avoir une
expérience visuelle ce soit
la mieux adaptée obtenu que chez sony on
sait faire particulièrement vrai des
contenus cinématographiques celui ces
boîtes multicasquettes effective au plus
tard partitionner la partie audio la
party gaming la partie smartphones et
que sais-je encore du coup l'idée c'est
quoi c'est de se dire dans nos
smartphones mais le meilleur de ce qu'on
sait faire dans une poche
venlo en fait confie sur la vidéo sur le
divan à l'elysée qu'il essaie vraiment
de d'avoir avec le xperia non plus le
smartphone qui puisse les petits curieux
les contenus de qualité et la vision
chez chez sony c'est de rapprocher des
utilisateurs des créateurs ce qu'on a
voulu faire avec ce smartphone c'est
essayer d'avoir un smartphone qui
peuvent avoir la meilleure capture vidéo
possible bloqué quasiment
en terme de qualité d'un produit qualité
et quelques professionnels ok avec
l'apix cinéma ferment vite à présent que
vous allez voir
[Musique]
photo avec capteur les nouveautés chez
sony va nous permettre de créer du sud
de tours
exposition quelle est la possibilité
créé une rafale à 10 images secondes
derrière choisir la meilleure photo avec
la meilleure lice était la meilleure et
épandre donc ça aussi c'est une fonction
qui provient
de la catégorie afin d'intégrer sur la
tronche yeasayer aidera vraiment à créer
un smartphone qui soit du niveau j'ai
envie de dire oui je continue que le
groupe dont 6 décès que le créateur de
son côté oui il a tous les outils pour
son smartphone pour créer et de l'autre
côté on a le même smartphone et on a une
qualité optimale son origine le
expérience et le smartphone dispose
d'une dalle 4 kg en led c'est la
première au monde en fait on est
dans certains cas les possibilités
c'était ma main
huit mois et les couleurs andy müller on
s'approche quasiment je veux pas faire
d'affaires mais d'un moniteur de post
production
donc en termes d'expérience on a sur le
stand d'une démonstration par l'écran du
supérieur est un moniteur oled
deux qualités relationnelles et je vous
laisse juge d'accord alors partie photo
optimisé partie vidéo optimisée est-ce
que ce format de 21 21 9ème donc bien
aussi pour la partie des minimes alors
je vais pas le vendre des moeurs ils ont
adopté depuis des années le 21 aviaire
c'est une vision périphérique c'est
l'ambition maximale sur les côtés nord
pour l'a d'ailleurs annoncé un
partenariat avec un jeu
quelles sensations ces derniers temps
fortin epic games le jeu sera
préinstallé sur le mobile et il sera
notamment utilisé en 21 devient d'accord
il y aura aussi une interface dédiée lui
permettra de bloquer les édifications
optimiser la ram et faire des recherches
directement sur youtube si on est un peu
bloquée sur certains niveaux donc une
application dédiée aux gamers
qui arrivera donc en termes de
performances performance donc ça braga
855 giga de ram 128 go de mémoire
interne extensible via microsd est
parfait produit
très élégante très fin très sympa on a
vraiment vu
joli et surtout voilà d'euros nets sur
un produit qui soit extrêmement élégant
et c est ce qu on fait de la recherche
rapide
on a de la chance jeu rapide compatible
power delivery auquel peut recharger le
50% du robinet en 30 minutes dans ce
produit là et
il sera disponible au mois de mai au
prix de 999 euros alors ensuite d'autres
produits dont tu nous parler oui donc on
a également adopté le 21 9ème sur deux
produits plus milieu de garde l'espère
ya 10 et les experts disent plus de la
période pectives 6 et 6,5 pouces tous
deux adoptés le zoom optique x 2 pour le
bail à dire plus cette folie vont vous
permettre notamment
lisez des effets bloquer des pulsions on
a une prise en main qui a extrêmement
facilité même si là on a quand même un
écran de 6 pouces 5
bien entendu on laissera aux
consommateurs le choix de choisir un
produit plus compact puisque on a deux
versions 1 6 pouces bien c'est +5 avec
une prise en main qui est extrêmement
confortable et notamment le capteur
d'empreintes qui revient sur le cas des
pour encore plus de simplicité
alors les résolutions d'écran que dirais
tu ces solutions d'écran on est sur du
full hd auxquelles vous voyez on a tout
de suite une immersion totale dans le
contenu cinéma ici la bande-annonce de
spider man film oscarisé tout récemment
[Musique]
on l'a eu l'idée c'est vraiment de créer
une immersion dans le contenu on l'a
fait sur le gamme avec l'expérience qui
à ce sujet d'ailleurs sont des soldats
tous compatibles
là dessus on aura
donc aussi le même confort visuel et le
même pas fort notamment pour tout ce qui
est multitâche
on va pouvoir optimiser au maximum est
géré au maximum d'applications sur ça
nous fait un smartphone tf1 qui est long
oui qui du coup puisque vue aux ex forme
à cette famille cran qui peut paraître
plus grand mais au final comme idée
folle je proviens endroit tout à fait ça
s'est vraiment bien c'est un désavantage
aussi du 21ième ont la dent l'adoptent
si pour un meilleur confort meilleure
prise en main sur le produit et les
usages vidéo aujourd'hui explose tous
s'accordent à dire pour passer non les
montants sur son smartphone notamment
sur de la vidéo
donc on sera là non aux clients payants
cioni se montrait ravi d'avoir à l'écran
6,5 dans la recherche d'accords en
termes de pertes françaises de la
reproduire ni comment on est sur des
sables deragon 630 estime francis très
bien effectivement espaly situe à 10
plus de pouvoir giga de ram donc
et confortable pour un usage tout est ok
bon génial est ce que tu me vois autre
chose à rajouter sur dans les geôles 10
et 10 plus sont disponibles tout de
suite oui chez nos clients opérateurs et
les distributeurs je vous mets le lien
en bas ça va tu as donc respectivement à
l'est mais dans le bon sens à 349 et 429
euros
et puis le il faudra être un petit peu
passion pour le xperia un oui il sera
disponible fin mai donc il fallait
s'armer un petit peu de patience mais
côté photo côté capture vidéo
également on a
on revient on revient sur le devant de
la scène avec ce produit là quelque
chose de l'humour de différent un vrai
parti pris qui ont appris qu on a décidé
de réaliser avec les internautes
viennent pas mais
l'idée c'est vraiment d'avoir le
meilleur écran possible la meilleure
restitution possible des images ont même
eu l'idée
je suis la mère fait la meilleure
capture mobile aussi bon écoute on
regarde ça et puis on en reparle au mois
de mai merci beaucoup ça viendra merci
merci à toi merci tu pas ce que vous en
pensez personnellement j'aime beaucoup
ce format 21 9ème au début le lauréat
dont il sait y perd grans mais peut-être
un peu trop grand et au final non alors
point vraiment positif et très
intéressant et ça ça effectivement c'est
un peu loin dans une poche peut-être que
ça pourrait potentiellement dépasser un
peu ça dépendra bien évidemment de votre
poche avoir forcément mais moi je trouve
vraiment bien parce qu'il est fin donc
il ya une très bonne prise en main toute
attente ou glissant et encore de toute
façon vous avoir une coque de protection
de sitôt franchement ça n'a pas bougé
savait vraiment bien mais surtout c'est
une immersion c'est très grand très
large on va beaucoup plus en profondeur
dans ce qu'on regarde c'est vraiment
hyper ats
alors sony ce qui est vraiment génial
avec cette boîte c'est que l'on maîtrise
l'audio c'est incroyable le cinéma on
sait sony pictures le jeu vidéo le
gaming avec la playstation sony
rossellois de multi casquettes c'est une
boîte à plus de 360 degrés et moi j'aime
beaucoup leur smartphone ils vont
vraiment dans le bon sens qu'on a eue
avec clide z3 il n'ya pas longtemps elle
l'idée c'était vraiment d'avoir un écran
bravia roulettes dans votre poche là on
voit qu'on va encore plus loin avec un
nouveau format cherche complètement
aller plus loin à se réinventer ça c'est
vraiment intéressant
il ya quelques années il ya même un an
si vous en souvenir au regard des p o
critiques un petit peu le le design de
souvenirs c'était un peu old school que
globalement il n'avançait pas énormément
que c'est un peu classique
là je trouve que on
moins d'un an ils ont fait un boulot
extraordinaire on se remettra
complètement en question avec un design
qui est revu et corrigé alors ils ont
passé des faits d'avoir une encoche
woods aux compagnies chacun son adn mais
en tout cas sont vraiment leur propre
adn et notamment dans le fait d'aller au
niveau d'un écran 21/9 d'aller chercher
plus loin la sensation immersive le
cinéma voilà donc face à ça vraiment
intéressant à vous de me dire ce que
vous en pensez en bons commentaires est
ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ça est ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec le fait que
sony va dans le bon sens que c'est
quelque chose qui pourrait vous vous
tentez vous marquez tout s'appuie pour
l'instant retenu il ya encore plein de
choses à voir ce n'est pas terminé
[Musique]
on a beaucoup parlé 5g dans le cadre du
mwc est parce que forcément la 5e j
arrive c'est ce qu'on veut
et là c'est la partie champagne de
qualcomm très sympa et sur le même stand
vous avez au chili
cette très bonne place et plein d'autres
encore réunies au même moment au même
endroit au bord de champagne tout ça par
qualcomm parce que le pôle corps il pas
vous savez avec les stands dragon's
équipe beaucoup de device beaucoup de
mac ça c'est intéressant alors par
contre j'en ai partout ça commence bien
ça promet par contre prendra très
prochainement de la 5g parce qu'il ya
plein de choses à dire vraiment
comprendre ce qu'on peut en faire les
enjeux les usagers en réalité qui est ce
que ça va changer dans nos veines
ça c'est intéressant
là juste derrière vous avez la soirée
one place du mwc
grosse soirée rencontre deux équipes
adorable maintenant il est temps pour
moi d'aller bosser joué 2 3h montant
jeunes cool pour la vidéo vous regardez
maintenant voyez c'est back to the
future c'est cool je vous emmène quand
même je trouve qu'ils coup d'oeil entre
copains on a passé une bonne soirée je
vous laisse découvrir et je donne rendez
vous demain pour regarder ça c'est cool
le programme n'a gagné un problème là
les gars ayvaz bon apparemment le macvin
pro serait meilleur que le s10 plus
alors bonjour à tous messieurs le
producteur ici présent je ne vous dirai
pas son vrai nom
d ça et il faut se rappeler que le
médecin et sorcières quasiment six mois
entier
c'est quasiment respectée
alors quand un iphone reuters ça coûte
cher quand on nous dise quand
s'étonnerait pas le résultat aujourd'hui
c'est strictement voilà c'est privé tout
ce qui se passe à barcelone bonjour
monsieur cameron
le coup de coeur du nws
tout ira bien dressés
comme cela je dirais le ricoh view 3,6
rozier moi c'est les archos
mentionnant à lui à dire le note mais il
est toujours bloqué le pire des maux
bleus
le magic
c'est dans l'air
toi coup de 15 heures
ces passionnés sur coup
le vieux boucau revue
c'est parce que
les sacs à patates j'ai pu prendre en
main respect il est hyper hyper
intéressant
[Musique]
ok
+10 5 g
ok 2009 il ya un seul appareil qu'il
faut aller voir sur le salon c'est le
energizer pékin reste ça energizer
spécifiques à ses infinies phone avec 10
unités en faveur de batterie
c
mais mam
44 il cherche pas par moi [ __ ]
[Musique]
alors la royale toutes les questions sur
les poches
[Musique]